scuba will throw in the mid to upper 90s
he's considered the tigers second best
prospect coming into the season
here is eddie rosario he and josh naylor
the only left-handed hitters in the
lineup today for the tribe
here is the payoff pitch and a line
drive and a base hit in a right field
the indians strike first
on a two-out rbi knock by eddie rosario
young man by the name of aaron chevalie
who's had good success against the
tigers
will get to start for the cleveland ball
club
nomar mazzara in the cleanup spot today
as miguel cabrera gets the day off
the 1-1 fly ball right field wow goodbye
no mar mazzaro with an absolute no
doubter
right first of the year 2-1 tigers in
the first
boy you're absolutely right you're
talking about a no doubter looked like a
breaking ball in the inner half of the
plate well with two down here's austin
hedges
the one-two swing in a pop-up playable
this time
castro will go onto the outfield grass
and cross into foul territory make the
easy grab
in foul territory by about a step
and a good job by tarik skubal after the
double with chang with two outs he
strands him at second base
we head to the bottom of the second
inning tigers are the 2-1 lead over the
indians
we'll get our first look at a youngster
that was so impressive in lakeland
florida for the tigers
akil badu leads off the bottom of the
third two to one detroit
it's a moment a young man has been
living for his entire life
granted akil badu just 22 years young
what a spring story he was lefty against
righty savali's first pitch to badoos
swinging the fly ball left field this
one's deep it's got a chance
and it's gone oh my goodness
[Applause]
and he goes opposite field into the
tigers bullpen and just picks up
where he left off this spring three one
tigers in the third you can't make it up
what a buggy whip
this incredible the first pitch he sees
never played above a ball and he hits a
bomb out the left field
here's jamer candelario savali
pitch count starting to climb he's at 45
the runner goes
the pitch is swung on a missed hedges
high throw to second the batter
interfered with hedge's throw
that should be a double play
and it's going to be and willie castro
the banner
walkton scored his first time up switch
header batting left-handed
the pitch castro bunts third base side
great bunt bare hand grabs spinning
throw by savali
got him oh what a play by aaron savali
on what looked to be a perfect bunt by
willy castro
daddy rosario the batter in field back
rosario grounds one on the right side of
the second baseman this will get a run
home
scope will throw out the indian teddy
rosario
but he has a second rbi of the game as
scoring from third is hernandez
and ramirez goes to third and the
indians now trail in this ball game
by a score of three to two now the tying
run 90 feet from home
two down in the sixth fran mill reyes o
for two today one for nine in the series
the one-two pitch swing and a mess he
got him on strikes
a heck of a pitch back-to-back
change-ups in front mel reyes strikes
out and norris does a terrific job he
strands that potential tying run
at third gets two easy outs we go to the
bottom of the sixth inning in detroit
three two tigers
you chang the banner infield in line
drive and it's up the middle and through
rosario scores the tying run naylor
comes home with the go ahead run
what a job by you chang he jumped on
that pitch
smoked it up the gut and the indians
have the lead
four to three one down
two runs in tribe up four to three top
of the order jordan luplow oh for two of
the walk
now the set by norris here it comes
it's swung on hit high hit deep to left
down the line it goes
fair ball and a two-run home run
he hung a breaking ball and jordan
luplow
didn't miss it a towering two-run homer
down the left-field line and the indians
have a six to three lead
scoring four times in the seventh
luplow getting his first hit in rbis of
2021.
cesar hernandez will bat right-handed
cesar hernandez since reyes chasing and
what a grab by mazzara in right center
field
took away extra bases from cesar
hernandez
what a running grab right where the wall
angles out in right center he leaped up
as he reached the track and made a
terrific catch on what could have been a
triple for cesar hernandez
how about that home run by mazzaro now a
heck of a catchment
here's victor reyes ground out and a
strike up
now the pitch swing and a miss he went
upstairs with the hard stuff and struck
out reyes
and that's a heck of a seven inning
start maybe he's not even done
you know is dominating right now grandma
reyes the banner
one for 10 this weekend today has flied
out popped up
struck out the pitch
a swing and a high drive in the deep
left
badoo is back track wall gone
fran mill reyes has his
first home run in rbi since 2021
and buck farmer went to the slider one
time too many and a towering two run
homer to left
by fran mill reyes and the indians have
erupted
for six runs in the seventh and eighth
innings
and are now blowing apart the detroit
tigers
by a score of eight to three austin
hedges leads off tonight
the indians in great shape beating up
the tigers now
eight to three hedges oh for three
a foul out two fly outs the pitch and he
swings and drills one to deep left
down the line it goes gone
the indians have their third home run
austin hedges with a laser down the left
field line and it's a 9-3
indians lead two outs in the ninth
inning
that leads it up to willie castro now
the payoff
straight three call ball game
clause a painted the outside corner
and the indians get win number one